all over the internet people are
obsessed with strange food combos that
you may never dream of trying it may be
your worst nightmare or maybe you might
be surprised in fact
weird food has over 70 000 posts and it
turns out sometimes the oddest pairings
actually work anyway today we're
tackling weird food trends that went
viral on social media and we can't do a
weird food tasting without our drew's
crew member and social media chef the
brilliant ayton bernath hello
i come to be here
and we have two guests and i'm so
excited please welcome sydney and connor
hello welcome i'm very excited to try
these with you okay sydney connor i
understand sydney you're in politics
transitioning to producing yes okay and
you're an editor yes yes uh writer and
technical editor yeah what's the
weirdest food combo you guys have ever
tried a chocolate covered cricket
delicious i had crickets in a margarita
once i loved them yes it was like doused
in like hot pink himalayan sea salt and
like roasted it was real crunchy and
delicious sounds good um what about you
what's your weird food combo ah when i
was a kid uh i i used to you know those
little like cheddar cheese blocks i used
to love eating those with like granny
smith apples
oh that's not weird
well the kids looked at me weird that's
what's important they're the problem not
you all right let's first stay tuned
and take it away i'm your passenger yes
this was a crazy viral thing on tick
tock where people were putting mustard
on their watermelon lizzo gave us a try
i love it who doesn't love whistle and
lizzo gave it a try and after a few
times she was just still very confused
and
drew not gonna lie i have tried this one
before and i was pleasantly surprised
you're giving a more even coating than
me i'm just going for it
spreadage would be good yeah
[Music]
uh not that bad
it's okay it's not that bad that's hard
do i want more probably not
is it bad also not no yeah it's it lands
in the middle for me yeah what do you
think i prefer the salt on it oh i love
salt on it
you know i'm not a big watermelon fan
but the the mustard adds a kind of
interesting texture to it yeah
these actually don't blend at all for me
and they just oh yeah yeah
they're both doing their own thing they
are not in harmony yes but i don't hate
it speaking of not in harmony next up
we have ranch and oreos now this one yes
this one
was all over the internet as well and
some people dip it in ranch some people
ready for it drew just go all over it
who likes this you know we did try to
remember we tried sweetie's um spaghetti
tomato sauce and ranch which you liked i
it is this just so weedy as well um it
is not but hopefully it'll be sweet i'm
a little worried oh that's a little for
me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's a hard no
okay
this is i'm kind of tripping out because
you like it it well is there anything
that ranch could touch that you don't
like that's my question i guess that's
the part of the problem okay so when
you're on a movie set which i grew up on
you go to a catering truck every day for
lunch it's i have a breakfast burrito
every morning and the ranch salad for
lunch and this is like my entire life so
this is giving me that salad but with a
dessert finish it's the weirdest thing
i'm like i'm having memory and
association so i'm i don't know what to
say about this i think if we put ranch
on a shoe you'd like to you know what
anton you know me so well it's true i
would love ranch on a shoe all right
next up we have one that i don't i don't
think it's that weird next up we have
white cheddar cheese with nutella now
cheese and chocolate is like a thing and
apparently people like to do hazelnut
spread cheesy sandwiches so you just
want to get a nice big dollop i love the
word dollop get some on there get more
oh okay um
okay okay i'll take a ranch and an oreo
any day yep that gave me feels this is
disgusting i think the texture was was
challenging who the hell is eating this
combo i'll tell you what not us anymore
uh connor sydney thoughts
it tastes like chalk
oddly enough i'm the odd one out that
isn't bad it doesn't look terrible
well good i'm glad someone someone liked
it
oh you know what it's the cheese
that cheese is not good yeah the texture
is a challenge there okay okay just
okay
i know i'm craving more of this yeah
anything to get that taste out of my
mouth okay well
this is always informative always fun we
learned something new um now we know um
please
tweet us with your favorite unique food
combination using the hashtag drew's
food combos
mine is bananas dipped in sour cream and
crunchy bacon bits so like anything goes
so tweet us tell us weird food combos we
love doing this segment sydney and
connor thank you so much thank you thank
you
and please come back
[Music]